welcome back Terry
thanks for having me back Martin
so our last YouTube video together
showed how to build a three-tier
application using Cloud run and it
kicked off some great discussions in the
comment section yeah no I was keeping
track of that it was uh great to see
people ask like really great technical
questions about the architecture it was
awesome
right I thought we'd look at another one
of your template applications the one
called storage event function app
yep we call that one scalar for short
because it's an image scaling
application and that's much easier to
say it shows you how to write an event
driven serverless application do you
want to dig into it let's do it
[Music]
first off let me install your demo
application go to
deploystack.dev I scroll down to storage
event function app here
click it and then I go to opening Cloud
shell
that opens the installer in Cloud shell
I hit enter to continue here I authorize
access
I'll pick a project to install the app
in I'll pick this black project that I
created ahead of time
then it asks me for region I'll pick you
as Central I'll go with the default
bucket name and default location of us
now the installer is running let's give
it a few minutes to finish installing
all right it finished now that I
installed it what does this application
do Terry well there are two parts first
the function that listens to any file
that's uploaded and resizes it second
there's a small Client app that shows
the files that are present and you know
actually allows for uploading ah very
good I'll go to the end point called out
here by the installation script
hmm okay it asked me to select an image
I'll pick this one then I click upload
it says that it's processing the image
I'll refresh the page here
there is the uploaded image I see the
thumbnail on this page if I click the
thumbnail yeah there it is it shows me
the original big image
now if I go to cloud storage in this
project I see the bucket here if I open
the bucket I see the original image
which is multiple megabytes in size
and the original that's that large image
click it aha here it is
all right and then uh here in the bucket
next to the original is the thumbnail
version of it
S size in bytes is much smaller than the
original image of course
if I click the thumbnail uh-huh I see
that its dimensions are four smaller
than the original so everything's
working uh Terry how did you design this
application
well I wanted to write an example
application that was event driven right
reacting to image uploads is probably
one of the easiest and most canonical uh
to understand examples right so once
this was created I needed a way to see
the image so I created the the second
app the web app actually if you look at
the architecture diagram the most
important part of the app is the cloud
function here it's triggered when a new
file is uploaded to cloud storage bucket
the function contains the image resizing
code
okay why not resize the image in the
cloud run service over here it handles
the upload after all what files can be
uploaded in many ways more than just
through this app maybe there's a mobile
app or maybe another microservice that
uploads files to the bucket or maybe
someone puts files directly in the
bucket maybe there's a batch process
somewhere uh somewhere else that someone
is uploading lots of images at once
instead of doing everything in the
uploader we can keep things decoupled by
using events in this case we run a
function whenever the file file added or
file created event is fired so the cloud
run service is only there to provide an
easy way to upload images it's not
really part of the event processing
that's right ah I see that cloudron does
two things it serves HTML to the browser
and it uploads files in our last video
you used nginx to serve HTML I left out
nginx for this app for to keep things
simple right like Cloud run can serve
static HTML but if you want to do it
scale maybe nginx depending on use cases
is a better choice you can even consider
using Firebase hosting if you want to
use a CDN
got it and now how did you set up the
cloud function to be triggered by file
uploads well there are two ways to do
this first when you deploy your Cloud
function with the gcloud command line
tool you can add options are those
options sell Google Cloud there's a
function should be triggered by uploads
to a particular storage bucket right
that command looks familiar to me what's
the other way Terry
you can also deploy Cloud functions with
terraform when you install the app a
minute ago you actually ran a terraform
script this is the part of the script
that deploys the function and tells
tells it which storage bucket to watch
for
got it let's have a look at the source
code of the cloud function uh here it is
what are we looking at here Terry well
the function takes the metadata for the
file in the bucket we then use an image
manipulation library to resize the image
and save it back to cloud storage I see
let's go back to the architecture
diagram tell me about the CI CD layer
here sure Cloud build uses artifact
registry to host the built image for the
cloud run service to use and it also
publishes the function I see and can I
use this application as a template for
my own event driven applications well
it's open source so totally you can do
that right tweak the function and rerun
the terraform script
so use cloud shell it comes with
terraform installed edit the function in
Cloud editor and then run this terraform
command ah and what is terraform
terraform is an open source uh
infrastructure as code software tool
that lets you predictably create change
and Destroy infrastructure it can be
used to set up cloud based and
infrastructure the VMS networks
databases Etc in this project I used it
to create the cloud function the cloud
run service and the cloud storage bucket
I see and how would I deploy a new
version of this function here well let's
edit this and retry so open Cloud editor
in your project
then navigate to function.go in the
folder code function
go to the line that executes the convert
command
change x 100 which means the thumbnail
is 100 by 100 pixels to something else
let's say X 75.
now save the file
now go back to the cloud shell and type
terraform apply and rerun the script
all done
very good I'll hit the URL again I'll
upload a new file here
uh-huh
and there it is 75 by 75 pixels
excellent thanks for showing me your app
Terry and thank you everyone for
watching use Terry's app as a template
to build your own app that handles
uploaded files
if you have any questions for Tara me or
serverless topic suggestions for future
episodes please add them in the comments
we read every single one until next time
[Music]